gene welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Thank You sis and honor to speak to you
thank you for joining us all right I'm
gonna dive right in and start drilling
you with some questions what's your net
worth it varies
somewhere around 1.8 to about 2.4 my
husband says my husband keeps track of
everything and how it changes I'm gonna
call it jam I'm gonna call it an average
about 2 million and what's it invested
in it's a lot of its cash that we're
ready to use when we need it and some is
our home how much is in your home
anywhere from 500 to 700 like we had to
sell it maybe 500 but maybe if we were
lucky more I got you okay and then you
got a bunch of cash and what's the rest
of it invested in mutual funds different
mutual funds and like your 401ks and
stuff yes yeah how much is in that in
the 401k a lot the rest is 401ks and
then some that are not 401k sy my
husband's expert at that okay so so
million and a half anyway yes
and what's your household income been
through your were average working
lifetime the highest it's been is around
200 but it's actually a little lower my
husband's which positions you may what
have you made most of your life what
have we made most of our life so a lot
lower probably between the two of us
like maybe a hundred but when we first
were married we were in school and
working part-time - I was working
part-time minimum-wage jobs and but how
much did how much did you inherit of
this money zero and how little gifts
here and there yeah that's zero how old
are you guys I'm 53 and my husband is
almost 50 - okay all right
and what careers were you in we were in
the army and then we got out and went
back to school and my husband is an
engineer and I was a public school
teacher but now I must
home home school mom okay so his degrees
in engineering years is in education
yeah okay all right and what was his GPA
and engineering oh he's very smart
perfect he was the top of this class
okay what about you
I was this average I was very very
average my undergrad wasn't so great but
in graduate school is much better I was
just very average
have you used debt to cause you to build
this wealth how much have you used none
we never the only debt we've ever had is
the homes that we've owned we and this
is just the second home we've owned but
we don't owe anything on our home but
we've never we've never lived paycheck
to paycheck we just always are pretty
steady and just moving up and living in
our means and living how many how many
new cars have you bought not many not
any was just one since we've been
married and that was a very small one it
was just because it was during that
what's the most expensive pair of blue
jeans you've ever bought the most
expensive since we've been married
not much I tend to shop it at thrift
stores and Goodwill stores and still yes
there were two million dollars you buy
your jeans at Goodwill yes fun and and
we get great bargains and it's a lot of
fun and it's a win-win situation there
what's the most you ever spent on the
nicest blue jeans you ever bought
probably before I was married like 30
years ago
30 30 dollars talk to me talk to me
about y'all's patterns around the
subject of generosity
how much does generosity pay to played a
role in your thirty years of being
married oh it's so important and and the
way we don't have a set amount that we
give or is that percent it's kind of we
like to give when we see it and when we
know someone needs it and we tend to
give more overseas because we like to
travel overseas and what we see
when we see people in need that's the
easiest way to to give or what we've
been involved in organizations so let's
let's talk to the 25 year old version of
you and your husband they're sitting out
there's a 24 year old couple sitting in
a lobby right now they just did their
debt-free scream last hour tell them
what the secrets of becoming a
millionaire by the time you're 53 are
what do you say caused this working
together as a couple
definitely working together just be
little by little you've got to work
together and live within your means and
how did you end up with two million
dollars just working really hard and
living with armies and not buying things
that aren't necessary or things we don't
need and thinking of others or not did
you ever go a whole year without
investing no never graduate school not
even when we were always investing
always investing yet Jean your great
American success story tell your husband
thanks for his service to his country
I'm so proud that you guys are worth
over two million dollars thank you for
letting me take your time today thank
you it's an honor to speak to you you're
wonderful huh it's a millionaire themed
hour we're finding well from real
millionaires how you doing not what
somebody's theory is on the talking
heads or a political party but how you
really become a millionaire and what
it's really like to talk to them
you